[Musique]
toutes les chansons parlent d'amour très
bien commençons par les chansons sur le
désir landes contre ma du mal à trouver
l'amour quand on se noie de danse
ah oui nous prises le coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment désolé pardon donc les
chansons qu'on écoute
elles nous disent quoi et nous moi c'est
ça rappelle les mains
c'était simple rencontrer quelqu'un dans
la rue
[Musique]
et on sent
son d'un coup d'oeil les voix qui se
hérissent une poussée d'adrénaline
[Musique]
on l'a ressenti tout l'été les carrément
trop génial un hommage et je suis
contente pour toi parce que cet homme
que tu vois la réé mais quand on écoute
une chanson pour la première fois elle
remue des choses justice
[Musique]
si je cours un coup
une artiste pas vrai
[Musique]
rien n'est jamais parfaite je crois plus
du tout rend la perfection ce que je
veux c'est là
gestion et de l'harmonie et et pour ça
il faut promet
[Musique]
mais il ya eu un accident et je t'aime
j'ai simplement peur que notre relation
n'est plus le moindre intérêt pour toi
ce que je veux dit que ça marche
se taire les voix des autres écoutent la
tienne ce qui doit arriver arrive point
barre
ce que je veux
à dégoter en toutes circonstances
[Musique]
alors chanté que vous soyez triste que
vous soyez heureux que vous soyez
croyante
[Musique]
son nous définit elle raconte l'histoire
de ce combat elle
je suis le robinson colons de la 24e
mission je filme ce qu'on est en train
de faire parce qu'il semblerait qu'on
soit les premiers humains a tenté de
transformer en vaisseau spatial en
bateau à voile
on sait bien flou
[Musique]
c'est une cascade
mais ce qu'un jour on pourrait arriver
où on veut sans se cacher pour autant
lâcher dit oui
[Musique]
je vous aime tous
tu es en train de penser eurobonds moi
aussi je voudrais qu'il seul on doit le
retrouver
il faut qu'on essaye au mans ce robot
est la clé de notre survie à tous
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce machin
pouvait passer tout le monde ils sont
tous partis tu sais pourquoi les
monstres qu'on pille un petit truc là
on dégage au plus vite et on oubliera
tout ça il faut qu'on pense à notre
survie
[Applaudissements]
une vie normale nous attend quelque part
faut juste qu'on la trouve c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît j'ai rien à faire moi
votre boulot c'est de rester là et de ne
toucher à rien elle supporte pas que
quelqu'un d'autre fois l'héroïne du jour
toi et tes soeurs et votre mère
[Musique]
vous protéger mutuellement
je mens
ici vous les robinson qui accueille
reçoit
mesdames
tous les gars
à
on est vraiment obligé de faire sa mue
oui je crois
c'était pas plus tard que je suis un
agent spécialisé dans la localisation et
l'exfiltration de tâches loi je
t'apprends que deux trois mots pour te
défendre
zappant le coût du lion fait voir une
foule si les voitures
comment tu te fracasser voir où ça vient
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
à cette fin
non witnessed
dans le génie civil
jusqu'à ce que
/
[Musique]
tu m'oublies déjà au début j'ai cru que
c'était perdu six nations temporaire
mais ça fait des mois que ça dure et
c'est de pire en pire est d'avoir
accepté de le laisser partir
il n'est plus là peut pas être au point
tu sais que je tombe on a une réunion de
famille ce week-end on sera tous réunis
pour la première fois depuis sa
disparition qui en dit quoi moi si on va
parler une brouette
mais c'est devenu n'importe quoi du
cloître est dans ton bureau je regarde
même plus regarde-moi effet à mes yeux
elle est de quelle couleur l'amarone
bien souffler mais ça c'est de la triche
bonjour bonjour mon seul petit secret si
toi et tes plus grands
parfois je décroche mon téléphone pour
l'appeler puis une souvient qu'il est
plus là je ne vois toujours tu vois
c'est mieux que les autres en chef fathi
quant au fait tu vois je crois que
j'étais trop présent avec toi mais trop
pressant certainement pas tu étais
jamais là tu me voyais pas tu vas jamais
faire de boire
si tu devais employer un mot pour me
caractérise et qui choisit quoi et oui
quoi tu l'as pas vu on t'a vu flotter
[Musique]
deux mois
je t'interdis rien fait tout ce qui
permet de sentir vivant
pour rire décodé qu'on tire crier
c'est par trois voitures pauvres excusez
moi pour la voiture on depuis trop mangé
un bien bonjour marie c'est pol pot le
cola j'ai rencontré votre père la
semaine dernière je vois que vous avez
fait connaissance je pensais pas que
vous alliez venir
[Musique]
nous vivons comme du thé le moins on
fait du chocolat c'est tout pour le
moment
on savait pas compter
[Musique]
j'ai rêvé d'un homme il n'était ni jeune
ni vieux nous étions ensemble faibles
efforts à la fois
[Musique]
le passé fauqué reste à sa place
tu as compris que tu vas vivre sans moi
maintenant élever lui sans toi il
tiendrait dans ses mains fermes et un
cadeau très précieux mon pied pour
ouvrir la boîte de conserve du coeur
on voit bien oui ça va tu viens
[Musique]